Speaker 1: I'm going to start today with the the
prototypical story really that is an objectively
important story to understand what's going on in
the economy and that almost no one cares about and
almost no one will watch or engage with. But it
doesn't matter. It's actually an important story.
So we're going to start with it in the story is
that the Federal Reserve has raised interest rates
by what's called sometimes 50 basis points or
half a percent. When they say 50, what they mean
is 0.50%. This is the biggest increase in 22 years
since the year 2000. And so much of what's going
on today that is flippantly mentioned and in so
many of these 2022 debates that you can tell the
candidates don't really understand comes down
to understanding what is the impact of raising,
raising or lowering the federal funds rate. And so
that's what we're going to talk about. And before
I get into the details. Yesterday we watched and
we livestreamed the 2022 Pennsylvania Republican
Senate primary debate. This is the one with Mehmet
Oz and Dave McCormick and Carla Sands and Kathy
Barnett, etc.. Bartos, I think is the fifth guy.
Now I'm actually remembering their names and they
were asked, all of them asked about inflation and
balancing the budgets and the economy and so many
different things. And all five of them expressed
no knowledge whatsoever of how these basic
tools that are available to different government
entities work. With the exception of at one point,
Mehmet Oz mentioned raising the rate to lower
inflation, and that was true. But then he moved
on and went beyond that. So let's jump into the
details and then we'll explain what's going on.
Yahoo! Finance Report Fed Raises Interest Rates
0.5%. Largest move since the year 2000. Good.
This is the short term interest rate.
This is an effort to tamp down on the
inflationary pressures weighing on Americans.
The central bank suggests that it will further
raise borrowing costs throughout this year
as it attempts to undo its pandemic era
easy money policies. The policy setting Federal
Open Market Committee also detailed plans on
unwinding its nearly $9 trillion balance sheet.
The raising of rates a half a percent is the most
aggressive increase in a single meeting since
May of 2000. Over the last two decades, the Fed
has opted to raise interest rates in increments
of a quarter of a percent only. So let's talk
about this. How how does the rate goes up and
inflation goes down? How does that work? Well,
when you raise the federal funds rate, you make
it more expensive for banks to borrow money. When
it's more expensive for banks to borrow money,
they in turn make it more expensive for people
like you and me and businesses to borrow money.
When it's more expensive for us to borrow money.
We do less borrowing. And when you see the ways
in which this is impactful, it will start to make
intuitive sense. So if it becomes more expensive
to get a mortgage, that's one form of borrowing
that makes a $300,000 house more
expensive. What I mean by that is
the house might be $300,000 either way, but if
my mortgage on it is five and a quarter percent
instead of 5% now that same $300,000 house is
more expensive for me. So instead of spending
300,000 on a house, I might only spend
290. So that pushes down people's budgets
and it can push down housing prices or at least
slow down the increase. That's one component.
Vehicles. Car loans. If car loans are more
expensive, you might be less likely to get a car
loan. Or if you do, you'll get a cheaper car. That
pushes down on price increases, it discourages
spending and it can lower inflation. Now, many
people will say, but, David, it can also slow down
the economy. Well, how how does that work? Same
principle. One of the ways that an economy grows
is by people investing in their own businesses.
Oftentimes, people, times people borrow to invest
in their business. Imagine that. I want to start
a shoe business and I need a factory and I need
to borrow in order to build that factory. Well,
if it's more expensive to borrow, I'm less likely
to do it, or I'm less likely to borrow as much.
Meaning that instead of maybe having $400,000 to
build my factory, which would go to contractors
and lawyers and insurance and local businesses,
now I only have $300,000, so I'm slowing down
economic growth in that way. It always is the case
that every one of these decisions is a double
edged sword. It is always the case. And so very
often you see hyperpartisan discussions where
we shouldn't raise rates because that will slow
down the economy. Right. But it could also lower
inflation, which many of you claim to want to do.
Well, we shouldn't lower rates because
it makes it too easy to borrow,
and therefore it will cause inflation. But, yes,
that that's the that's the way it works. That's
the double edged sword. And the whole strategy,
the whole trick of it is to keep these things
in balance. One other way in which raising
the funds rate discourages spending and
it can both lower inflation but slow down the
economy. If if anybody has a savings account,
I was going to call it a high yield savings
account, but there's very little high yield about
it. Many so-called high yield savings accounts
over the last couple of years at the most pay
about half a percent. There's a number of high
yield savings account where you can earn 0.5%.
Not a great incentive to just store your money
because it's lower than inflation. If the federal
funds rate goes up half a point and thus high
yield savings accounts pay you more interest, you
might lean a little more towards now a more. Okay,
just saving the money and earning the interest
because the interest rate is a little bit
higher and instead of putting that money
into the economy, you just save it. So that that's
another aspect to this. Every single one of these
things can have multiple effects, and that is the
importance of raising the federal funds rate. So
we'll see what the impact is and we will see what
forthcoming additional increases there are. And
we've been we've been warned to expect more. I
hope that that's clear, or at least relatively
simple. If it's not, let me know and also let
me know if these types of segments are useful.